let's talk about the bachelor lets you
know bachelor nation I'm trying to
because we have tons of questions here
from people what do you think everyone
can expect from your appearance on The
Bachelor presents listen to your heart
what your part is that yes
so Oh Jason just opened the door
remember what I exude said don't come
down here I'm on that's okay I'm talking
to show from each camera you can take
the dogs out if they want to come yeah
okay so yeah Jason I are on listen to
your heart so we ended up being able to
be on the finale of the show so we're
with Jewel and Rita Wilson and Taye
Diggs and we get to actually pick the
winner of the whole show so I obviously
can't say who at that point it is but
yeah we get to you know they are the
professionals there to judge the vocals
and Jason I got to be a judge of the
chemistry for the couples so it was
really fun that you're perfect for that
that makes time I'll be honest woman the
show when I first heard of the shows
like yeah I don't know and then I
watched the first night and with halfway
in it was like it's we're back
most ABC and The Bachelor and the
producers and everyone that runs that
show knows exactly what they're doing
they put out great TV and I was the
exact same way I'm like oh boy another
like you know kind of bachelor show and
then I'm like I like the scene a second
then I watch night one from I come in
yeah right okay but you're also you're
you're a dancer you're a singer I mean
you that's right up your alley that's
perfect you just love anything that has
to do with performing it's so fun yeah
are you loving chick talk yes I was such
a like I was judging it before I even
got on it so I was like you know my
niece and nephew are on it I was like I
think it's for young young like young
kids and then I started getting into it
I'm like oh no this is this is like my
jam this is where I'm supposed to be its
tick-tock
yeah it's so much fun you know what's
funny though is I actually preferred
doing the other tic TOCs
rather than dancing I don't know why I
just love the like funny lip-syncing
yeah yeah like the funny stuff yeah yeah
it's good but I do want to see some
dancing because I know that you're a
really good dancer so we need to cease I
should do more tic toc dancing you're
right I really enjoy it yeah but I also
like to see Jason hold his own beside
you I feel like that would be very
entertaining so if you could just give
me a little bit of you and then I just
want to see if he can do it he's he's
got rhythm he's not the greatest at
picking up choreography but he but he
has rhythm and he would be good if he
just committed a little more to the
choreography well tell him Canada is
counting on him to get it together okay
all right so which current couple let's
get back to this new heart which current
couple or individual are you rooting for
the most asked you that because you
helped me not I'm rooting for a couple
that I can't say who because I know too
much that's right so yeah let's do that
question no but I think I'm gonna chat
with them Julia from from the season on
an upcoming episode of the podcast too
so that'll be good she is she seems like
a really sweet girl who well I don't
know it's only been one episode but so
far I like her
okay so far you like her that would cope
in 19 the filming of Claire's season
obviously has hit the skids yeah um how
do you think she'll be as a Bachelorette
oh my gosh I was so excited for that
season because it's been a hot minute
since we've had like I do not want to
say older woman cuz 30s are not old
that's in with a season life yes yeah
someone who has some life experience who
is really like I think you just the
older you get the more in tune with
yourself you become and I just feel like
she's a person who even tell she she's
all about self-care and self-love and
she I just think she's she's in a place
in her life where I would believe a love
story and I believe she's there to find
it and knows what she wants so I was
excited for that season everything
happens for a reason I think they had
needed to recast to the guys I think
they were too young I think they're
gonna be able to do that but when it all
comes like I think she's gonna have the
opportunity and I think it's gonna be a
really really great season that's good
no yeah because I did hear that some of
the guys were in their early 20s so Mike
what guy in their early 20s wants to
settle down and have babies like it
makes no sense
no it doesn't I mean not that there
aren't any other that wouldn't but the
majority or not and and I just feel like
not there's nothing wrong with the age
gap but that's a pretty big age gap
absolutely Marshall so what advice would
you give her having been through the
process you know having been in love
right now like what what advice would
you give her um oh it's so hard because
I just think I think it's really
important in those moments to be present
with each guy like I think it's really
important to not do what you think all
the viewers want you to do and how
they're gonna react you have to kind of
cut out all the noise of what other
people think you should do and really
like be true to yourself with each
relationship because that's the only way
you're gonna find your person and it's
it's hard for me to say this because
producers also know what they're doing
but I think it's important to like stand
your ground with with producers as well
I would tell her that like make sure you
you stand up for yourself through it too
because a lot of times you know it's
it's for some good TV but I think you
have to listen to your heart at the same
time right well they're gonna push it in
one direction and see how far they can
push you that's their job and you've got
a new age yes exactly that is their job
and that's you know that's why we love
watching but yeah I want her to like be
strong with that as well yeah and then
what advice would you have for her
coming out of it because I feel like
when you're in the show it's one thing
but then when you guys come out of the
show and years later there's a lot to
that of there's just so much from
there's a lot your personal life to your
career like the judges
it is a lot it's
it's I think a lot more than people
would would think because it seems like
the glitz and glam and fun interviews
and your traveling the world and you get
all these opportunities and it is but
it's also heavy and you're dealing with
a lot of emotions especially when you
pick somebody if you pick somebody it's
hard on that person and it's hard on you
because now you're reliving everything
that you've already kind of gotten
through so when you're watching it back
you're kind of reliving the past which
who really likes to do that so it's it's
hard so I would say honest opinion
therapy honest honest opinion sense
though I think it's very important I
think the show should support that I
think they should set you up with
therapy after because it is nice to talk
to somebody that is a professional and
that can help you because there's a lot
of outside noise that can get to your
head so that I would say and then also
to lean on people like us who have gone
through it and we're there for you you
know we're going to be a vault and and
want to help you through everything and
we're not there to get headlines from
you or do anything like we can relate
and not a lot of people can but also
clear has some experience with going on
and then coming off the show so I think
so I think she'll navigate it pretty
well that's right I noticed you Pete on
the podcast yes now it's great you think
he handled everything I mean that turned
into a real storm at the end like
there's a barbed storm that was a
barnburner yeah it was crazy I really
did not think the ending was gonna I
knew it was like okay it's not spoiled
and whatever but that finale was I don't
even know the word to describe it it was
insane it was like it felt like it felt
like barb got too much airtime that
sheet I don't think she wanted I don't
think she even knew she was on that
little barb cam in the bottom box the
whole time no no woman no no no and
she's very expressive so I don't know
how to say everyone handle it because
it's live television in front of
millions of people and the
amount of pressure to not say the wrong
thing or act the wrong way
I think Peter could have said a little
more with to his mom like okay mom but
not talk about this after you know maybe
not now well yeah he just seemed pretty
quiet and then barb - I think she could
have you know just waited till after but
I mean she's a passionate woman she is
she's a you know loving mother who wants
the best for her son so it's hard to say
how people handled it because I don't
know how I would have either I just he
just looked like so defeated at the end
he was like yes mom like he knew he
couldn't fix it he knew it was just
going in in in the you know where so it
was just I agree I feel like he just
seemed very defeated and I think deep
down in his heart he kind of knew it
wasn't gonna work at that point either
so he was just like how could it at that
like I mean but he seems happy now he
does seem happy now
he's getting very have any scenes
himself and like goofy and fun and like
able to be who you know himself and it
seems like Barb's a big fan of Kelly so
so there you go yeah Kelly I mean it it
works